Will Ferrell might be one of the funniest
people on the planet.
But even though he makes people laugh for
a living, he's not immune to the power of
his own jokes, especially when he and his
co-stars are improvising gags on the fly.
So what makes the funniest star in Hollywood
laugh?
Here's a look at some Will Ferrell bloopers
that make us love him even more.
A glass case of screw-up
One of the most quoted lines the classic hit
comedy Anchorman is the moment when, during
a breakdown in a phone booth, he shouts
"I'm in a glass case of emotion!"
But as this clip shows, it took him a while
to get there - and the mistakes were almost
as funny as the final take.
"Drew, do it again?"
The other bloopers
How hard must it be to film a scene with Farrell
when he's in the middle of one of his stream-of-consciousness
improv moments?
In The Other Guys, dramatic actress Eva Mendes
found out the hard way just how difficult
comedy can be when you're playing the straight
man to one of the funniest guys in Hollywood.
"Doctor said it was similar to operating on
a German shepherd when they have hip dysplasia."
It's just science
Part of Anchorman director Adam McKay's job
is to keep the jokes flowing.
So when the improv slows down, he pitches
in with ideas to get his stars riffing - which
backfired spectacularly on the set of Anchorman
2 when he suggested a very unusual material
could be used for the filler in breast implants.
"What else did I have…"
"Nickels."
And they just could not pull it together.
"The problem they're running into now is whenever
a woman runs…"
This outtake is so hot right now
Before his breakout role in Old School made
him a Hollywood star, Will Ferrell spent his
time as a supporting actor stealing scenes
in other people's films - like when he played
Mugatu in Zoolander.
Luckily, he soon got his own movies, no doubt
thanks to moments like this one:
"Waaaah!
WAHHH!"
Hey, tantrums sometimes work!
Something extra
It's hard enough for superstar actors to keep
a straight face while working with Ferrell.
Now imagine how hard it must be for extras!
Well, you don't have to imagine, as this slip
up on the set of Daddy's Home 2 had the whole
room breaking character.
"Look at here, she's standing on the, GIVE
ME A PHONE, GIVE ME A PHONE, GIVE ME A PHONE!"
"I don't have a phone, props never gave me
a phone!"
Talladega lunch
One of the best loved scenes in Talladega
Nights is the extended sequence where Ricky
Bobby's whole family gets together for dinner.
"Chip, I'm going to come at you like a spider
monkey."
But co-star John C. Reilly loved it just a
little too much, as he couldn't quite keep
a straight face during filming.
"I sure as hell am, Chip.
CHIP!"
Bloopers of glory
The skating comedy Blades of Glory is a just
a minor entry in Ferrell's catalog of comedy
classics, but it sure looks like the cast
had a good time filming it.
"Of course not."
"I shouldn't do the sound effect, eh?"
Ferrell and co-star Rob Corddry seemed to
have a particularly hard time keeping a straight
face together.
"You smell like urine."
"I would fire you if you weren't so goddamn
beautiful out there."
Behold the majestic wolf lamp
Step Brothers is the tale of enemies who become
family, and then become friends - just like
Ferrell is clearly good friends with his frequent
co-star, John C. Reilly.
Their camaraderie is on full display in this
ridiculous scene involving Ferrell's "majestic
wolf lamp:"
"This is Galco, which is Hebrew for 'kindness'."
"Galco?"
And it just kept going.
"You can't put a name on the innocence of
that face."
Live, from New York
When you crack up filming a movie, you can
just film it again to get it right.
But when you crack up on live TV, there's
not much you can do except go with it, as
Ferrell found out after having to introduce
Tim Meadows as "Dr. Poop."
"The truth is, we misplaced your baby."
And that's not the only time Ferrell cracked
during his time on Saturday Night Live.
"We're going to the Dolce & Gabana show.
How fast can you have your bags packed for
Milan?"
Keep on laughing, Will!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!